منذ مونديال 2010 استخدمت العديد من
الحيوانات في التوقعات الخاصه بنتائج
مباريات البطوله العالميه اولها الاخطبوط
بولت شغل العالم في كاس العالم 2010 في
جنوب افريقيا بعد تحقيقه لعدد جيد من
التوقعات الصحيحه ومنها توقعه فوز اسبانيا
بكاس العالم ايضا الباندا الصيني كان في
مركز للحفاظ على الحيوانات الباندا في
الصين وتوقع العديد من نتائج مونديال 2014
في البرازيل لاسيما المباراه الافتتاحيه
التي تغلبت فيها البرازيل على كرواتيا
ايضا من العرافين القطه خيل وكان قططا
اصاما وظهر في روسيا خلال مونديال 2018
كان ناجحا في عده توقعات ومنها توقعه
نتيجه مباراه مصر وروسيا في دور المجموعات
في قطر الان اثنين من دببه الباندا سهيل و
توقعان نتائج المونديال وفشلاف الكثير
منها اهمها توقعهم لخساره السعوديه من
الارجنتين حيث حدث يومها عكس ما توقع
الحيوانات العرافان